hello reject nation its Greg Alba yeah
it's Andrew here so Andrew from the
movie source channel is here at me today
because he loves to play his video games
and I've been editing with John all day
today a sketch and I finally made some
time to sit down with Andrew to watch
this thing thanks man
Marvel's spider-man PGW to 2017 teaser
trailer his like a story trailer
actually alright tease right there
what's next
safer than ever Oh baby Peter Parker can
no no it's not gonna happen
take care of this place it represents
the best part
smiles it's gonna be helping out our
whoa your city and everything you care
about will be destroyed it's a body said
thank you for help
let me a mr. negative yes yeah
[Music]
Wow
like wrong gritty
[Music]
Wow
[Music]
[Music]
maybe the city needs our friend
[Music]
shop shutters in their graphics think he
said the words stole the words right in
my mouth that looks amazing man that's
amazing you know I remember the first
time we saw the e3 trailer I was saying
like I'm really hoping that this time
they really enhance the story and
capitalize on a great comic book story
full-on story right there with a lot of
emotion I got just got some hardcore
nipple chills right now that was really
awesome that was Dennis I can verify
that and you got a whole world yep you
got a whole world of characters in there
I mean we got see kingpin Norman Osborn
I guess or negative Mary Jane Watson the
Shocker the Shocker Miles Morales that's
what I'm interested in because they
teased him at the end of the last
trailer and now we're seeing him again
here I'm wondering if he's gonna have a
bigger involvement in this actual story
I mean it looks like Peters gonna be
mentoring him obviously in some kind of
a way so someone he looks up to and like
obviously not a surrogate father kind of
role but more like a older brother yeah
and that's the vibe I was getting we
only got to see baby teasers but I'm
liking already the chemistry and the
cohesion that they have when they're to
when they're just the little dialogue
they have together the cinematics on
this little spider-man movie yeah and I
like how Mary Jane was talking like you
know you need to try and balance out
that life between being Peter and
spider-man it's like no not gonna happen
so there's gonna be obviously a lot of
conflict there there's gonna be an
emotional core there's gonna be it feels
like a lot of human depth in terms of
like the moves that spider-man is doing
in the game I mean the hand-to-hand
combat looked incredible remind me a
little of the Arkham Asylum and Arkham
video games Batman of course I've seen
that obviously moves like this in other
spider-man video games I mean cuz I
basically played them all for the most
part my favorite move was on like when
he's in the car he breaks through the
one-way do that another game so I'm
really curious to see what are some
other even though that is sick and with
the graphics it just really goes well
but I'm just kind of curious to see are
they gonna do some moves or some stuff
like that we've never been able to see
in any other game and obviously they've
shown so many different things that say
how many more new things can we show for
spider-man's but if they can figure out
a way to do that on
the incredible story looks like we're
gonna get in all the incredible villains
and obviously we get Mary Jane and miles
and all that that's gonna be one other
caveat of bonus I'm gonna be laughing
for extra like cool sick moves that
we've never seen in a spider-man game
what I really thought about when I was
watching this in terms of how's me moved
by just its story and like feeling and
watching a trailer for an animated movie
reminded me of what I felt like Sony was
trying to do when they did the amazing
spider-man reboot let's go for a more
realistic touch a darker vibe but then a
guy went a little too far there in
certain areas I just did a mesh well
this seems to have the right blend of
color and superheroism backed with a
kind of a gritty story kind of a darker
tale of Peter Parker and we've seen that
story done before too plenty of times
maybe I have a chance to stop being
spider-man yeah not ain't gonna happen
right like it still felt dark and gritty
while at the same time feeling light and
grounded and colorful yeah I'm very
colorful like almost a Superman seven
years that's what makes spider-man so
special is that good feeling you get
whenever he's doing it her own act
because you we can all relate to Peter
had such a obviously a relatable
character because the dark stuff comes
from the human emotion but it's not the
look like a dark piece of material oh
yeah yeah yeah the color palette is very
that was great fantastic trailer I'm
super I'm into this I will be going over
to your place to play this I have the
ps4 so you will be able to play this
perfect for me to be there make sure to
invite me maybe we should do some Let's
Plays together sometime Andrew I'm down
where we get really serious and focused
and we don't make any comment I might
see Greg and I fight on camera but it's
all out of egotistical love all right
guys you can subscribe to the real
rejects please click that notification
bell Andrew is a Gor 7-eleven on Twitter
and Instagram and he is at the movie
source channel here on YouTube folks
please make sure to check out our
patreon where you can become a patron
oject today a lot of good fun have you
had there